news of a new covert 19 variant detected
in south africa and in neighboring
botswana is creating panic all over the
world a number of governments have now
suspended travel from the country and
others in the region
now not enough is known about the new
variant but scientists fear that it
could be even more infectious than the
delta variant and that it may be
resistant to current vaccines
dozens of countries have shut down air
travel from south africa and neighboring
nations including namibia botswana
zimbabwe and mozambique
at the terminal you'll be waiting for a
test to return your results
it was bad news for at least 60
passengers who tested positive for kovid
19 after flying into amsterdam from
south africa
officials are carrying out further
testing to find out if they are infected
with the new omicron variant
the uk has confirmed its first cases and
is reintroducing restrictions for
travellers until more is known about the
strain
as always on our stresses with as always
with a new variant there are many things
that we just cannot know at this early
stage but our scientists are learning
more hour by hour
and it does appear that omicron spreads
very rapidly
and can be spread between people who are
double vaccinated
german officials announced that the
variant was in their country too after
passengers returning from south africa
tested positive
the world health organization has called
omicron a variant of concern with
scientists still unclear about his
potential dangers
it looks potentially quite a lot scarier
even than delta and don't forget we
thought of delta i certainly thought
delta as as peak variant and probably it
couldn't get much worse than that this
looks potentially worse
on the other hand there's no reporting
from south africa yet that cases are
more severe and it looks like vaccines
may still be doing something because we
heard from there yesterday that the
people in hospital tended to be the
unvaccinated people rather than
vaccinated
as travellers scrambled to leave south
africa officials there have criticized
the world's reaction to the discovery of
the new variant
the foreign ministry said it was being
punished rather than applauded for
detecting omicron
now
that's why we are saying that
the reaction of some of uh
countries
in terms of imposing travel bans and and
and such measures are completely against
the norms and standards as guided by the
world health organization
australia japan and canada were among a
number of other countries which
announced travel restrictions
as the world faces another festive
season plagued by pandemic woes
i'm now joined by adrian kriesh our
correspondent in south africa it's good
to see you adrian so how is the news of
this new variant being received in south
africa
christine the government already said it
is a rushed decision and a rather
unfortunate one and of course they have
the economic
impact in mind for many here in south
africa it's kind of a deja vu of what
happened almost exactly one year ago
back then south african scientists
discovered the beta variant here and the
same like with the current variant it
was discovered here but it does not mean
that it originated from here yet it had
devastating impacts for the economy many
countries banned flights um and south
africans to visit their own countries
and also the number of tourist arrivals
went down and this is exactly that we
might see it once again now i'm just
coming from a souvenir market here in
the city center of cape town and the
people i talk to they're actually
devastated
we are worried because since yesterday
we can't see again the germany they were
here
last week
they didn't come again they said they
said they must go back home if they
didn't go back home now they are going
to be locked here
it's bad because we suffer for three
years without business and now the
variances are gonna kill us how can we
survive how how the economy economy can
be left up so if uk germany they bend
the flight so meaning we are in trouble
and we are suffering uh to me it's gonna
be tough because i suffered a load for
these two years
so now i don't know what's gonna happen
yeah
the thing you see i don't know what
these people they are doing but us to
survive on this business
yeah without this business we can
survive
it's clear uh adrian that people are
anticipating um some more economic
hardship but
we're seeing more and more countries ban
travel from south africa because of this
new variant what has the government
there
in south africa done to respond
well south african president cyril
ramaphosa will convene a coronavirus
command council meeting
soon they say and it is likely that more
restrictions will be on the table then
you have to recall that things are
almost back to normally at the moment
the past weeks were very nice like
hardly any restrictions lots of tourists
in the country again but the numbers
have been slowly increasing and many
virologists say this is the beginning of
a fourth wave how bad will it be well
nobody knows some are hoping that the
summer that is currently starting here
although it doesn't look like with the
current rain but it is really starting
can have a positive impact that
infections are not spreading that easily
but on the other hand what is also clear
is that south africa cannot really count
on his vaccination program less than 25
of south africans have been fully
vaccinated so far less than 25 of the
population it's a very low number
there's a lot of vaccine hesitancy here
despite the fact that vaccines are
widely available by now
yeah you talked about the south african
government's lamenting of uh the sort of
knee-jerk reactions that a number of
countries have had i just wondered about
uh countries in africa have we seen
other african countries take similar
steps when it comes to restricting
travel to south africa and from
well kenya said they're closely
observing the situation but they don't
want to come up with any restrictions
yet it's the same for several other
countries so the big question will be
will we also see travel restrictions
within the continent it's too early to
tell but what we can see for say from
the past there were a few examples for
example nigeria imposed travel
restrictions for some time for south
africans so it is possible but generally
it hasn't happened often
all right that's adrian chris talking to
us from cape town there thanks adrian
when it was south africa which first
sounded the alarm on army cron many
governments have now imposed travel bans
from where from there and the wider
southern african region dw's adrian
kriesch reports
here at the airport in cape town you can
see a lot of anger frustration and
uncertainty in a lot of people's faces
some flights have been cancelled the
remaining ones leaving the country are
almost all fully booked for days in
advance it's terrible it's really
terrible she wants to be back with her
family
she's got her
grandchild there and everything so yes
it's very emotional
and you know what else can i say
let's just hope for the best yeah
everything's fully booked overbooked you
can't get tickets here
you don't know when you might get home
i have a family and three small children
waiting and i really want to go home
it's all very strange
everything was fine when i flew in on
november 11th
there was no hint of this variant
the last two weeks in cape town have
been great it's my ninth visit in three
years they're trying to get the economy
going again everything's safe
i have a lot of german friends who also
traveled here
everything went mad between nine and 11
a.m on friday morning
it's chaos incomprehensible yeah
unfortunately i'm from uh london uk i'm
trying to get home today for people that
work abroad like myself um it can be
very difficult and
we were starting to get that feeling
that it may be behind us all this and
now it seems to be coming back tenfold
for many south africans the discovery of
the variant is a reminder of what
happened one year ago back then south
african scientists discovered the beta
variant which resulted in similar
reactions to what we see now many
nations shut down their borders which
meant that south africans couldn't
travel there anymore but it also
decreased the number of tourist arrivals
here this is what many working in the
hospitality industry are fearing now
again all my clients
wanted to come next week quickly
cancelled we have already 40
unemployment
um that means in the restaurant sector
coffee places sector
all the tourism places nobody will come
and that's
i can't tell you what will happen so it
will major impact everybody's just
gotten to a point where there was hope
for work
we've gone through a heavy period with
certain tourism companies and
hospitality has suffered through this
whole period of covert and it seemed
like people started coming back to cape
town and there was some new hope and
then all of a sudden it just disappears
within one morning's decision where
airline chooses not to to take people
from here
i think it's very sad you know what i'm
saying because these companies that's
losing their companies
myself i'm i'm self-employed
i possibly might lose my vehicle no work
no money no no income
so it puts you in in a difficult
situation even if you look at this the
poor people that's come two days ago
they're all in a state of panic and
everybody wants to fly out of cape town
summer basically the beginning of the
major tourism season has just started
but with restrictions in place the
airport here in cape town will once
again look much emptier than before the
pandemic
all right well we're joined now by dr
owais durani he's an emergency medicine
resident physician in san antonio texas
welcome to dw um what is it about this
variant that has governments around the
world so worried
yeah thanks for having me whenever you
know over the course of the last year
and a half i've heard about ovarian i
asked three questions
is it more transmissible does it lead to
more severe disease and does it render
our immunity whether that's through
vaccines or natural immunity
less effective right now we only have
the answer to one of those questions it
appears to be much more transmissible
and even more transmissible than the
delta variant and so that is the reason
for worry we do not have the answer to
this two other questions we will find
out those answers over the upcoming
weeks but i think the worry is that you
know if they render our vaccines a
little less effective if it leads to
more severe disease that combined with
the increased transmissibility could be
could be bad
right now if omicron proves resistant to
the vaccine could we be back to square
one in fighting this pandemic
yeah so that's you know a worst case
scenario and hopefully that's not the
case but let's you know say we do end up
in that situation i wouldn't say we'd be
back to square one first of all i think
having immunity from our current
vaccines would at least give us
protection um against severe disease to
some extent also both pfizer and moderna
have said that in the course of a
hundred days they could adjust the
vaccines to kind of tailor me
taylor attack it to omicron and so 100
days plus you know getting regulatory
approvals and whatnot we'd still you
know in the course of a few months be
able to get a vaccine that would be
protective so it wouldn't be a square
one but it would be a setback for sure
all right b it'd be a setback but what's
the best way then to contain omicron
yeah i think going back to the
principles that we've been talking about
for the last two years you know here in
the united states for example we've
really let our guard down on masking
masking is going to be key you know
ensuring that we're not getting into
high-risk environments again so closed
indoor environments where now it's cold
and we're interacting with a lot of
folks that you know may not be masking
may not be vaccinated um kids are you
know still going to be vulnerable so
essentially kind of going back to that
position of masking you know staying in
your bubbles and really waiting to see
what this virus is how dangerous it is
and how you know we're going to react to
it
all right briefly
we've seen how flights are being banned
from particularly southern africa
do you believe it's too late for that in
some ways
i think so you know we don't even know
if this variant initially originated in
south africa the reason south africa is
in the news is they have really good
detection systems and they were able to
sequence it and realize that this
variant exists and so the fact that it's
you know spread to numerous countries i
imagine it's already in the united
states it just hasn't been caught by our
surveillance mechanisms here and so i
think travel bans might you know slow
the spread but eventually this virus is
going to get to every corner corner of
the globe
dr oas durani thank you for your
insights
thank you
you